la conclusión más importante es el
compromiso de la donación de mil
millones de dosis de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 que deben llegar entre lo que
queda de este año este segundo semestre
de 2021 y el próximo año pero además los
países del g7 se comprometieron a doblar
esfuerzos para la recuperación económica
de todo el mundo también para prevenir
futuras pandemias especialmente para
estar mejor preparados para atender
alertas tempranas para desarrollar el
máximo 100 días nuevas vacunas y
tratamientos para futuras pandemias
pero otros temas más bien importantes
también es cortar la influencia que
china está teniendo en países
desarrollados invirtiendo en proyectos
de infraestructura además el cambio
climático viene importante se
comprometieron a reducir el uso del
carbón conservar y proteger el 30 por
ciento de los territorios de la tierra y
del mar a 2030 y además aportar
para proteger el medio ambiente y
controlar lo que más se pueda de la
temperatura global y aportar también
grandes recursos para la educación de
niños y niñas de millones que no van a
las escuelas como la estrategia más
clara para cortar ciclos de pobreza